so I know you've been asked a lot of the
same questions I'm gonna try to mix it
up a little bit the first being the most
important did you see the game of
Thrones finale and what did you think
okay
don't say a word I didn't watch that
sounds it dies oh just guess what I
heard I haven't seen it we've been
working right so you are watching it
though last one and I have been staying
off of social media because I don't want
any spoilers watch you watch it tonight
tonight right now did you watch it I did
what did you think I did enjoy the last
episode I'm not doing any spoilers that
would ruin that for you
millat to say but I'm gonna be very
respectful with saying too much more a
favorite unscripted moment that made it
in the film in this film or any although
there there are with Evan so when we
come back from the from space and he's
like standing there that line that you
said were you like I basically did
everything it was Oh me yeah that was
him that wasn't scripted right no oh
yeah evan has some real gems about your
favorite moment that didn't make it in
the film oh I may need account you guys
he's a beast flight flight lessons you
guys see that any extras really really
really I didn't say anything like that
I did hear there are some deleted scenes
good there's a lot I have heard and I've
heard some of those will be on the
blu-ray um do you have a favorite person
to work with and why
favorite sense hmm I mean I don't really
got it I like throwing people under the
bus yeah just name one person everyone
else feels bad i Nick and in his beast
he's one of the most hilarious things
yeah where's these leopard print
flip-flops his feet don't get dirty it's
like there's a little the little cups
with the straw I see for each of you do
you have or ever have had a like a pre
shooting ritual like right before you're
about to shoot something you do this
sometimes music yeah I remarked practice
my lines mm-hmm yeah for me I'm just
coffee
did you steal or borrow any uh props or
costumes from any of the movies you've
been in yes yes I still a lot of things
I'm a klepto on set this watch this is
the Cyclops what really I think I can't
really if this is the last time you
played these roles because who knows
what's gonna happen with the future of
the Fox does anything but you think
you'll take away from the experience
well what will you take away from this
new experience I mean I think it's been
I mean it's not only is it great to
shoot these movies because everybody's
like a family but the movies about
family it's about inclusion of you know
people that are sometimes seen as
outcasts and so I don't know I think
carrying that message and trying to you
know portray it wherever wherever you go
is one of the most important things I've
learned from it I guess yeah I love you
guys so fun I mean honestly it's so much
fun
everything about it's been pretty
incredible and surreal and and yeah it's
been amazing
yeah I'll take you guys away I love the
sequence when you guys are going up in
the ship it's in the first 15 20 minutes
of the movie yeah and it's like it you
get to see them as a team all United and
you know it's just an awesome sequence
can you talk a little bit about filming
that thing and did you realize when
you're filming it was going to turn out
to be so cool we were in that ship for a
week because they have to end when they
when they built the ship when they were
shot interiors inside the ship we
basically had to put the door on and it
was secured for like you know maybe an
hour to you had like a certain amount of
shots you have to get so you're kind of
locked in they really went ham on the
design can I tell you it was pretty up
to scale if it like if it was real that
would have been it you know they had the
doors bolted on and we are seatbelts
like we were really seat belted in there
like they was it was moving around this
great LED screen they made it look like
space we had stuff to look at would you
rarely get when you're doing special
effects like it's like green screen
you're like do it but not only was a
great reference for us it's also an
interactive then we all can react to the
same explosion for not like a domino
effect right it's hard with green screen
but the ship was really cool because of
how interactive and like up to scale and
like real it felt yeah yeah it also it
looks great on on screen and it's just
the getting to see you guys a team
fighting together it's a really really
well done sequence or adult diapers do
you remember your first movie or TV show
crush Jonathan Taylor Thomas sorry that
was too fast I was going to say that you
had that pretty pretty quick yeah Olsen
twins great one mmm that is a great one
oh wait what movie do you think you've
watched the most the Fifth Element
yeah so cam it back to gammon
but do you smoke um I've seen Fight Club
probably a hundred times really mm-hmm
I am Jack's overworked spleen Wow and
the things you own end up owning you yes
I've also seen the movie a lot can you
watch yourself on screen or do you have
to like look away well it's pretty
painful when you watch it I find are you
really nervous really yeah I can't do
anything about it I think I mean when
you get past just like to watch for
everybody else yeah yeah go team and the
visual effects too
yeah especially these movies there's so
much fun because you don't know what
they're gonna look like in the end
summary it's always a surprise even to
us you know who knows the story that's
what that was yeah yeah I'm like
watching myself my life I think it's not
gonna be my last question but what was
the last thing that you've really been
obsessed with whether it be a book a
movie a city you visited Zelda a
Nintendo yeah the switch pretty deep how
is this great yeah just I play it all
poor the portable version that in bed
was the last thing you really got
obsessed with whether it be book movie
TV show video game this is I'm gonna be
a total girl I'm obsessed with skincare
right now so I've been just trying out
all different types of skincare I'm
really into glossier right now she's
sponsored by the last year I'm not but
like sponsor me so I don't have to pay
out the ass for your products oh it
works early air streams air streams
airstream remodels and the very complex
I love it it is very complex my goodness
be doing a school bus she's making it
into a house yeah it's really cool I
like living on the lam all answer that
didn't expect Congrats on the movie for
real and thank you so much for answering
my stupid questions thank you my man
great to see you